hello everyone good afternoon yes
afternoon my name is Jimmy Bogart you
can find me on Twitter at add J Bogart
everything you see today code and slides
all that stuff will be on my github
github.com /j Bogart you'll see a bunch
of repositories there and I'll give you
the link to these at the end I blog
about this topic and quite a few other
things on my blog at Jimmy Bogart calm
there's a bunch of other junk about me
at the bottom but today I want to talk
about the exciting topic of distributed
transactions everyone's favorite
afternoon talk right this is a very long
title I could have just summarized it as
cloud is hard because that's really what
I'm talking about here's some of the
things that we ran into moving from very
simple systems where everything is like
nice and easy to reason about to go into
the cloud we're like everything is
everywhere and I can't really reason
about anything so most of my career I
was in a much simpler time in space
where I had this like very simple system
where I had the app and the database and
one or two when I wanted to interact
with the database which by the way I've
actually had clients who just have the
database that's still a thing out there
when I wanted to interact with the
database I just like through some secret
it and everything worked fine I want to
have some ecommerce system where I want
to update the status of an order so I'm
like update the orders were status is
three where I equals one two three and
everything would work just fine when I
wanted to get the information back out I
would say get that status back out of
the orders where that order is that and
everything was good dodged it actually
as I supposed to put a picture there but
I couldn't find an appropriate so just
everything was good I write some
information to the database it comes
back out and everything is as I expect
now sometimes things will get a little
bit more complicated and have to do
multiple things with the database so in
this case I'm not only updating the
order status but I'm also updating some
inventory information inside of the
database so I'm updating the status of
an order but also decrementing some of
the quantity of the stock because well
we don't want to sell something we don't
actually have an inventory so of course
we want to do those two things together
someone to buy something I'm reserving
that stock from someone else so I want
to do these two things together now when
I read that information back out ideally
the information that I just wrote is
exactly what I expected and again
normally this is all okay but you still
to do something special to make sure
that those two things both happen
together and what I want to have these
two things happen together if something
fails with Kalinda's operations then I
need to wrap it in something to make
sure that either all succeeds or all
fails and that thing I wrap everything
around in is really the fundamental
building block of the database which is
a transaction it either all succeeds or
all fails in fact there's an acronym
around this acid right
atomic cute no interesting dynamic
something like that I know it just means
like if I do this kind of thing where I
write multiple things to the database
and I wrap it either at all succeeds or
it all fails and if something goes wrong
with one of these operations then
everything gets rolled back to the
original state so for most of my career
I lived in this kind of easy world where
the most I'd have to do with any kind of
system I was dealing with it's just like
just make sure you wrap everything in a
transaction and everything was okay when
I would review my co-workers code it's
like oh you forgot to wrap that in
transaction you're doing multiple writes
make sure you do this otherwise it'll
partially succeed or partially fail
now early on my career like this all
works really well but sometimes I'd run
into these slight wrinkles when it
wasn't so simple that it had just a
single application in a single database
sometimes it wasn't just the database
sometimes there were two databases and
so in this case they'd have something
like a sales database in a shipping
database because maybe sales got too big
for the one single database way to split
it out into its own thing and so what
I'm trying to do now is split an
operation into these two different
databases I'd say first update the first
database with the order status and the
next update the inventory on the
shipping database with a second quantity
piece and then I'd wrap that whole thing
in a transaction and everything works
right well no it doesn't work because if
you try to do this without configuring
anything you
this like really horrible error message
that has like some horrible sequel error
code that's like zero three eight nine
seven two you know like that's super
helpful let me go look it up and then
you go look it up on Stack Overflow and
you get a bunch of answers that are
really disconcerting like okay something
about a distributed transaction unable
to begin okay that looks like a good one
but the next one is what is the
distributed transaction like oh oh when
the second answer is what is this thing
that's not a good that's not a good
that's not a good sign here then we have
okay now we need to detect whether in a
distributed transaction and the final
one at the end that's when you know it
really picked a bad thing to search on
Stack Overflow if the fourth answer
talks about soap you're in a really
really bad place so look at this this is
again very early mid-career are just
trying to open a transaction between two
sequel databases seem like so it seems
like a very reasonable thing to do
they're both sequel the both databases
can't you just like figure out how to
make this all work but no it's not that
simple because the transactions are just
around each individual database and so I
have to do this thing of a distributed
transaction so what is this distributed
transaction this is the this is the
general term for a more specific
protocol we'll talk about in a second
but it's distributed transaction is a is
a transaction in which two or more
network hosts are involved so basically
I'm trying to create a transaction about
and within one not just one thing but
more than one thing that doesn't fit
into the one transaction of that one
thing the most common way that people
try to do this is with the two-phase
commit protocol the general idea is that
the transaction boundary around one
single database has a very well-defined
way of working but as soon as I try to
go to more than one resource or one
server or one service whatever it might
be then I have to have something to try
to coordinate these two pieces now the
way the two-phase commit protocol works
is with well two phases the first is to
do your basic normal database
transaction II stuff which is to say
first I'm going to ask each of the
resources or databases can you do this
thing and go ahead and reserve it to say
I'm going to try to do this thing so
that'd be the first step to say go ahead
and prepare the transaction for this
commit step then each resource will tell
me can I
do this or not yes or no yes I can do
this thing or no I cannot and the final
piece is then to then say okay now go
ahead and commit each of those pieces
for each of the resources you notice I
have to have this third piece in the
middle here this this coordinator that
is coordinating these activities between
these two different resources something
has to be the arbiter of these two
different resources to coordinate the
activity to say it either all happens or
it doesn't happen all together but in
production we notice there is actually a
problem because there are cases in which
this protocol can fail in that second
part of the phase the second the to
phase the second phase of the two-phase
commit if something happens to interrupt
the communication with the second part
or how many parts there are if something
interrupts that piece right there at the
bottom then it's in this unknown middle
state because the first part is actually
finished committing and the second part
has not finished committing so if you're
going to do this you have to make sure
that these lines never have any
explosions in them basically so how do
you make sure that there are no
explosions in my lines you make sure
that those lines are really robust and
you make sure that they're really close
to each other so I don't have to go very
far away in order to do these things so
this kind of thing works if for example
both databases exist on the same server
if they exist on the same server there's
no network to hop and potentially
something go down there or it gets low
and everything's like right next to each
other then everything should work okay
but as if anyone here is dealt with a
juror you know that things go down like
all the time and so these blinds aren't
solid they're more like a dotted line
between these different things and so
you can't assume that these lines will
be very close to each other nor can you
assume that they'll be solid all the
time we have to assume that there are
going to be up or down at any given
point time so that means that this kind
of picture just just plain doesn't work
in the cloud but it does work in a lot
of scenarios so it can work if i have
two different sequel server databases
that works okay and we'll introduce this
thing in the middle that actually does a
coordination this is the Microsoft
distributed transaction coordinator by
the way if you mention that to your
operations person or network person they
will punch you in the face
because they do not like to have to deal
with that thing
by the way that only works if you have
all the different correct ports open the
security rules like Italy they like
takes a week to get those two arrows to
actually work for two different
databases assuming they're in the same
machine if you actually physically
separate it then it's just almost
impossible you just you just give up
um it also doesn't work if you happen to
flip the most expensive checkbox and
sequel server the always on checkbox
which like increases the that the spin
on sequels are from like reasonable to
like bugatti level like it's just
absolutely insane so once you turn on
always-on it doesn't support distributed
transactions and now you can't
coordinate between these two different
databases or of course if you're in azor
azor explicitly says we will never ever
ever do any kind of distributed
transaction protocol so just figure it
out for yourself we're not gonna do it
for you now there are some legacy
technologies inside of Microsoft that
can coordinate with each other so for a
good deal of my career I was using a
messaging technology that was built into
every single operating system since I
think in t4 which was MSM Q Microsoft
messaging queuing actually does support
distributed transactions so it could
have a single transaction that both
wrote a message to a queue and wrote to
the database and have those two things
either succeed or fail at the same time
however like nobody uses omit some queue
these days and probably shouldn't either
because that's state that's a queue that
actually lives on an individual machine
and we don't want that typically people
go towards more of a broker style model
where I have a central place where all
my messages are stored and have one
single place that I have to worry about
backups for stores availability things
like that and so a really popular one is
rabbitmq which does not support any kind
of distributed transactions so if I want
to have some kind of operation that
writes to a database and produces a
message I cannot coordinate those
activities with any kind of
transactional support and one of my
clients they found out the hard way that
some of the more fun databases the no
sequel databases of the world they don't
even support transactions within their
own
single database the only sports are Tran
track transactions for one single record
or entity or item at a time so it's kind
of a rude awakening we're like okay I'll
just write to this record write to that
record and assume they both happen or
don't happen but with something like
MongoDB it doesn't work that way you
either write to one record at a time or
you have to worry about what happens
when things fail so for most of the
systems that I'd worked with until
things got interesting I only had like
one app one database and everything
worked great as soon as I started to
make the jump into this distributed
transaction world I found out things
were a lot harder
so with this two-phase came in just to
summarize transactions within a single
resource yes that can work so if I have
transactions inside a database inside a
record that should work great if I have
transactions across identical resources
like if I if I bribe the operations and
network people enough maybe it could
work they open the ports for me but
generally it won't work if I try to
transact across disparate resources like
message brokers message queues logs
streams and a database that will not
work and then friendly transactions
across multiple items that's either a
yes or no yes if I'm using sequel or
know if I'm doing no sequel so with this
picture most of the time when I'm seeing
people build systems they're assuming
that the answer is always yes
like transactions will always work I
don't don't worry about things going
down but in reality things do go down
all the time especially if we're working
on Kyle providers that just like things
just go down as they do so when I first
ran into this not just in a way that I
could just kind of spackle over it with
opening ports was a project that was on
MongoDB and RabbitMQ now the reason why
they chose MongoDB is because they were
going microservices and the DBAs didn't
like micro services so they said we'll
go MongoDB because then we don't the
talk to the DBA s anymore but then they
had this problem that okay now we don't
have this ability to support
transactions between multiple documents
multiple resources so for them they were
trying to have a single operation a
single request that would write to
multiple
documents and be able to produce
messages on RabbitMQ and all their code
just assumed that this would all succeed
for them though they were a global
manufacturing company I mean you imagine
like the people that build iPhones like
that sort of level of scale and they
just like oh do all the stuff that just
assume yes I can just write all this
stuff to Mungo
write all the stuff to rabbitmq but
there's nothing that is that really took
an account that those lines are not
solid lines that are actually dyed and
lines things can actually fail so this
dealt with order fulfillment it was
consuming messages via RabbitMQ so it
was actually reading from a queue during
that operation it would write out to
data my Adibi doing multiple
writes
it was also producing messages via
RabbitMQ all within all within a single
assumed transactional activity that is
they would have a single block of code
that did all these sort of things and
they just assumed like it either all
succeeded it all failed but as we've
seen like we can't make that assumption
there's nothing inside the different
resources or like anything that we could
we could just pull off the shelf that
you could make all these things succeed
or all fail so we'll dig into the code a
little bit more but it looks something
like this in which they had that in this
case that we're dealing with MongoDB but
they had some wrappers and they do
things where they would first update a
single item inside of MongoDB they would
loop through all the items and the order
request and go ahead and update the
quantity for each individual stock item
and then finally they would notify
downstream systems by publishing at an
event saying yes this orders have been
approved because all the stock looks
good so go ahead and notify downstream
systems we can actually ship this order
but there was no like transactional
block around any of this and so when I
pointed out to them like by the way
something can fail right here and now I
have decremented stock but I have not
notified any downstream customers like
your customers are gonna be pretty upset
that this has happened okay that's great
well let's fix it okay well how do we
fix it how do we get around that there
is no transaction around each of these
things and that was the first thing at
Google by those like MongoDB distributed
transaction and basically the stack
overflow answers or just laughs like
haha no you can't do that or even ma
even rabbitmq it does have a concept of
transactional reads and transactional
writes but I can't I can't tie that into
whether or not MongoDB passed or failed
there's no unifying protocol or anything
that tries to tie all these things
together and there really shouldn't
because it's it's such a hard problem to
solve that we really can't solve it with
just something like a protocol or
something like that so when you google
this and you say like how do people
actually solve this in the wild I
actually ran across a paper from Pat
Helland
who is a I think right now he does work
for Salesforce at the time he wrote this
he worked for amazon.com he used to work
for Microsoft he actually wrote a big
part of the Microsoft distributed
transaction coordinator as well as my
sequel server has some kind of message
queue underneath it covers or something
so he was part of that as well so he was
very big for a very long time into like
making the database the thing that
everything flowed through and then he
just like throw more transactions at
this thing and it all worked
but once they went to a cloud-based
environment he found that that doesn't
actually scale it doesn't actually work
when I start to move all my resources
off this single box and start to
distribute them throughout different
data centers so I wrote this paper and
this is the basis of the title this talk
would just probably should have prefaced
that life beyond distributed
transactions an apostates opinion and
apostate by the way I think will define
it later but part of the epiphanies from
this is whenever you're building systems
is is if you want to ever get this to
any kind of scale that gets off a single
box then you have to assume that the
transactional boundary of your system
can only be a single item that is either
one table one row it really depends on
what you're trying to write to it could
be a message as well but your
transactional boundary can only be that
one thing so whatever you do to it be
able to coordinate your action with
other things you can only were of reason
about a transaction without one
individual item and he describes a means
of being able to do so he says well what
you the way you solve this problem is
instead of you trying to write to two
different entity
items at the same time instead you start
to use some kind of messaging with your
item so that you can communicate from
one item to the other and the trick is
to store your messages of that item from
one item to the next
inside the transactional boundary of
that first item so when I'm wanting to
communicate from this entity to the
other my transactional boundary includes
whatever business data I have as far as
that part that first entity and any kind
of communication I'll have to the
outside world when I want to actually
consume these messages that is
communicate from one entity to the next
and what we'll do is have some kind of
way to keep track of what messages I've
received so that I know like this met
this thing is tried to communicate with
me before but have I done it yet or not
so I start to keep track of the
different messages this entity's
received to make sure that I don't
accidentally process that message
multiple times and eventually get to
this more complex picture of why I'm
keeping track of conversations from
different entities from one entity to
the next and these messages are always
stored within the same transactional
boundary of that original entity so we
saw this like great we're gonna do that
but there's a problem
there was no code with this it was only
pictures of things like we'll just have
circles and squares and boxes and
letters but like nothing to tell me like
I'm on and I'm on rabbitmq how do
I actually translate that into a real
implementation something real behind the
scenes so we had to take that and say
well what does this mean inside of the
current system we're working with we do
have messaging we have rabbitmq we do
have something like entities but they're
documents inside MongoDB so how does
this translate into that picture so it
looks something like this we would have
each individual document that represents
the transactional boundary of MongoDB so
that represents the the things that can
write within one atomic operation that
can only be inside one single document
now I know if you go actually google
MongoDB transactions that there's a lot
of like marketing stuff that says they
can do transactions but
read the operational support and like
actually don't use this yet because we
haven't actually proven an out real in
production so for us we said okay that's
still like further down the line so our
transactional boundary then we can
reason about is going to be one single
document at a time this will of course
have the real business data associated
with what we're doing so we'd have all
the JSON junk associated with that
individual document but as part of this
would also include communication to the
outside world or to other interested
parties so when I wanted to communicate
with another document the head its own
business data they don't have to have
some kind of messaging structure to
communicate to the other piece and we
called it the outbox in my head I like
literally picture people as these
documents that have their own workspace
and when they want to communicate to
other people
with other things they want to have
happen then they have like a something
on their desk that has a piece of set of
stack of papers that says I want to do
something with someone else so here's my
outbox something else can go shuttle on
to the other people and every single
interested party that's involved in a
system has their own individual outbox
that is within their own transactional
boundary so what what I want to
communicate to other people other items
or resources that I will place items in
my outbox
and then something would then go deliver
them to the other side I do have to keep
track of these individual items so each
individual document has to have their
own inbox to keep track of things that's
received to know whether or not
anything's been processed before alright
so I'm gonna switch actually to a code
example to show how this might look in
real life now this example that I'll be
showing is using Azure cosmos DB because
really doesn't really work that
great locally and so cosmos TVs seem
like a good thing to do and I like
Microsoft centric conference so cosmos
DB I am still using RabbitMQ because
there's no way to run Azure service bus
locally maybe you can work something
else out you cannot
you cannot so it's using RabbitMQ for
messaging but as your cosmos DB went
through a local emulator for my
documents so the first thing I'll show
is how do I actually signify an
individual message so in this case I
just have a very simple interface an I
document message and the only thing it
has on it is an ID because there I have
to have some way to distinguish this
message to sent to someone else versus
this other message over here so in that
case I'll have an i document message and
then top of that I need to have that
container for the inbox and the outbox
so I'll have a a base class that
includes an outbox in an inbox and the
outbox and inbox are just a hash set of
document messages I hash it because I
want to make sure that if I get two
messages with the same ID I only store
that message once and if anyone wants to
interact with this document then they'll
need to work through these these inboxes
on the out boxes and because the inbox
in the outbox lives on the same base
document as everything else then this
all gets saved automatically each time I
write this document to Ashur cosmos TV
so with this primitive of having a base
document with inbox and outbox I can
start to build more interesting things
for example my order request is
inheriting from document base and
anytime I want to interact with anything
else then it will go through operations
in that document to be able to actually
persist eventually okay so now I have a
way to actually store messages received
and messages sent now I want to be able
to actually do something interesting
with my application because yes it's
it's fun to like save messages but let's
actually do something more fun
so I have this this this order request
object that can be able to store
messages needing to be able to sent to
someone else but I have to have
something that actually takes those
messages out of one document and sends
them on to something else and to do so I
will have something that takes messages
out and sends them along with the
dispatcher now the way this dispatch
will work is first the first operation
just do something inside the business
object or the document so as part of
that operation it will write some kind
of business data to the document and
then store messages inside the document
inside its outbox now the next step is
to be able to take those messages out of
the outbox and be able to train them and
transfer them out to the other dot
interested documents now again my
transactional boundary is the individual
document so each point have to say like
make sure I have a checkpoint as I go to
make sure that everything for that one
single boundary can either succeed or
fail
the dispatcher reads messages out of the
outbox it figures out who can actually
process those messages and then finally
passes them long to any interested
document and any interested document
then can then do whatever needs to do to
process information which can be reading
some information as well as storing that
message in its own individual inbox the
transactional boundary is going to be is
going to be each individual document
so as I'm processing information it's
changing the business data as well as
keeping traffic track of that message in
its own individual inbox all right so
let's look at an example of this
all right
alright so in this example what I've
done is created an order request which
is like me clicking the button on the
website to say place order and then as
part of that I take in a shopping cart
so the general idea is I'm trying to
convert my shopping cart into an actual
order but in order to actually process
the order I'm having to interact with
things like stock items and fulfillment
so I can't do that all in one single
operation so what I'll do is whenever
you create the order from the shopping
carts I will save all of my own internal
data which is the ID the customer and
the actual items that you purchased I
will set my status to new because I'm a
new order and then finally instead of me
actually telling the stock items to go
ahead and decrement the quantity instead
I'm going to send a message to them and
this sin is going to create not an
actual message on a queue anywhere but
this is going to create a new message in
the in on the out box of this document
with this information this order created
information it says my order created ID
order created ID for this message is a
just new ID the order ID in which this
order created message is referring to is
my own ID and then finally I'll also
make sure also include the line item
information so that downstream systems
when they receive this information know
exactly what is on the order itself so
this sim method is that actually like
sending a message to anyone really all
it's doing is just recording this
information on my document base class up
here and just adding that message to the
outbox and that's it
so when I actually process do this
operation of creating a new order
request I'm not actually communicating
to any other documents I'm just
recording the intent to interact those
documents be an outbox that is stored on
this exact same document itself so
looking back and where this actually
gets called this order request this gets
called on the button click of you
placing an order so the only thing I'm
going to do is create the order
best save it to the Asscher cosmos
database and that's it it's like I'm
just creating the item saving it to
cosmos DB and then something else is
going to take take that piece and then
deliver it to the other side and so that
piece is going to be the dispatcher that
takes that information out of my order
request document and somehow passes it
to the other side so that's the next
piece we're going to see is the
dispatcher the dispatcher is going to
take information out of those documents
the outbox and figure out how to pass it
to the whatever documents would be
interested in receiving that message so
there's a bunch of Cosmos DB junk in
here but the most interesting thing is
it receives a document it will loop
through all of the items in its outbox
and for each items in the outbox it will
find something that can handle that
outbox message that's going to be this
piece here it will pass that message to
that other interested party and then
finally when it's done it'll go ahead
and remove that message from its own
individual outbox so the one example we
had here was a order created message so
something is actually interested in this
document message and so the other piece
is going to be nope
it's going to be
I don't think that's the one either it's
going to be oh this is the one this is a
document message handler for that
individual message type so for this
message I've pulled off of my document I
have to find who can actually handle it
I find that there is a actually there's
a handler that can handle this and so
from here what I have to do is translate
that message into some other document
that can actually handle the information
so what I'm not doing is like like doing
kind of like explicit routing between
this document in the other I have some
kind of indirection that says well I
just have these document messages I
don't know exactly what you're going to
do with them so we'll just create this
interface it says anyone that cares
about document messages of this type
then you have some kind of handle method
to go ahead and go handle that whatever
that thing it is you want to do so for
this one I'll pull that order created
message off of the documents and then do
whatever I need to do for fulfillment to
actually process that information
so what fulfilment is going to be doing
is loading up the information from that
message and then creating a fulfillment
that is going to include the stock
information about how is going to
actually fulfill this order so in this
case what I'm doing is creating a new
order fulfillments creating that item
and then finally delegating out to the
individual order fulfillment document
itself to actually handle that message
all right so I'll stop here and
transition back to some of the ways
things can go wrong with this picture to
see how we can handle this through each
step in this process
okay so I'll put at this points I'm
really just still assuming that
everything can basically succeed I'm I'm
having a lot of indirection around here
to say well I can't write two two
documents at the same time so I'll just
use these kind of messages to to be able
to coordinate these activities but that
still doesn't help me when things can
potentially go wrong with that picture
now remember in MongoDB my transactional
boundary and comest cosmos DB is one
single document at a time so I have to
assume that every time I write to cosmos
DB that something can fail immediately
afterwards every time you see like
create item or update item I have to
assume that something will fail
immediately afterwards so in this
picture I'm like halfway through the
process now I've pulled something off of
my original document and have now passed
it to the first document and now it
succeeded but as I pass it to the second
one something goes wrong what goes wrong
I don't know it could be an exception
from a bug someone wrote in the system
it could be that someone pulled a plug
on the operation it could be that
communication was interrupted with Azure
or it could just be I'm in the middle of
deployment and I'm just trying to update
my software to get rid of the bugs
whatever it might be something can go
wrong with that second part of the
operation and so I have to be able to
recover from this picture so in our case
what we'll do is have some way of
retrying this operation and something
has to do this how do i how do I get
halfway through this operation and make
sure that something can go ahead and
pick it up and go on from there so
thanks this gets into retries I have to
be able to take at any point in that
those arrows going between each document
that that can fail and have to be able
to recover from that failure in order to
be able to make sure that everything
actually still succeed at some point in
the future so we'll do is have some kind
of notification that something went
wrong in this case I'm introducing a
message queue to say something needs to
be something went wrong go ahead and try
to retry this operation and so when I
retry this operation I'll do that whole
thing all over again that is I'll read a
message from the outbox of the original
document then I'll dispatch it to that
first document but I've already
processed
first message so I don't need to do it
again so this one just says it nothing
to do I've already done this so I don't
have to be able to I don't have to redo
this operation the second one hasn't
processed this message yet so it
actually will do whatever operation
needs to do to be able to process that
data so it processes the information and
then says yep everything's good to go
and so finally when we're done
everything says it's it's successful so
we remove that document the original
message from the first originating
document now everything is successful
and so this entire operation is complete
the only way this can work properly is
if I make sure that within each arrow
I'm able to check to see how I done this
thing before and if I've not done this
thing before go ahead and do the thing
otherwise I have to check to see and
then actually do the operation
underneath it covers so let's go back to
our code to see how does it actually
keep track and make sure I haven't
processed each of these things before by
the way if if everyone just goes wants
to go back to the world of a single app
in a single database like I get it like
I do - I missed those days when
everything was so simple it all just fit
in a single transaction and all was good
okay so in our first original operation
in which I was creating the order
and the order requests oh gosh yes I was
totally doing that purpose here we go so
this is the initial button click
handling the initial request to go ahead
and save the item in the database so I
basically go line by line like what is
gonna touch a database and what can fail
so this originates from a web request
which I don't have a transaction around
like no one implements transactions in
Chrome right it's not a thing people do
I hope not so there is some point where
I don't really have that transactional
support so I assume that this entire
thing someone could click the button
twice and then have to be able to handle
that so at this point once I'm done in
this level I have to assume that this
can happen more than one time so at this
point I go ahead and create the item I
in stage two the order request I create
the item at this point this is my
transactional boundary so at this point
things are good but everything after
this can possibly fail so I could
potentially screw up my carts I could
potentially not return the response but
I have to assume like this this this by
itself can either succeed or fail and
that's it now once I've actually created
them them the items with their outbox at
this point something is taking over and
that's my dispatcher so let's go to our
dispatcher to see how that thing can
fail my dispatcher is finding items that
have individual items in their outbox to
process and for each item in their
outbox it is saying go ahead and find
the handler call the handler and then
process the document message this
handler can be writing to the document
database so this is doing transactional
stuff so this can succeed but this may
fail so I have to be able to process
this all over again this handler may
have may execute twice I don't know that
so each time I actually handle the
document message I have to make sure
that can handle that this thing could
potentially be processed twice so behind
the scenes what you eventually get down
to the individual documents that process
the messages what they'll do is
inside the order fulfillment document
and won't just do all that stuff by
itself instead it wraps everything in
this process and says I'm going to
process this message this is the actual
work that will be done but what we'll do
is each time I process a message I'll
check if I've already processed this
message before then just return nothing
to do if I haven't processed this
message before go ahead and do the thing
that you told me you wanted to do and
then once you're done I will add this
message to my inbox so that every time I
process a message I'm not only doing the
business action that you are wanting to
do but also keep track of that thing
that you asked me to do so that the next
time in if something happens and it goes
wrong I won't accidentally perform the
same operation twice I'll always check
how my receive this message before and
if I've received this message before
then just return do nothing what that
does is it gives me the safety to say
that I can I can process stock
information and fulfillment information
multiple times without worrying about it
accidentally like doubles doing stock in
the fulfillment place or accidentally
charging a customer twice every single
time I'm processing something I'm
checking to see if I've already done
this before now this one actually
generates more messages so as part of
this processing the order fulfilment I
need to actually go out into the
inventory to make sure that all the
different stock items actually have
stock information or have the
appropriate quantity of where I'm trying
to do but each stock item is yet another
MongoDB document or cosmos TV document
that is in its own individual
transaction boundaries so I can't just
like if stock item is greater than
hundred do the thing know I actually
have to say well I I don't know if it
has enough stock so I'll go ahead and
stand to send a stock request to each of
the different stock items and then ask
them do you have enough stock to be able
to fulfill this item and let me know if
you do or don't so again I'm never
trying to have more than one document in
the same transaction because I can't
I can't do that so I had to split
everything into this communication to
these other documents back in by
dispatcher after that individual
document is been handled appropriately
that is everything seems to have
succeeded from that point then I'll call
process document message on the
originating document and what this will
do is just simply remove that document
from the outbox so it's effectively d
queuing the message but I don't have a
queue I just have a single document
boundary and so it's just removing that
message from that documents and then
finally saving that original document
again this could fail someone could trip
over the plug a juror could blip
somewhere so by having that inbox that
keeps track of whatever messages I've
sent to individual documents I ensure
that this whole thing can be retried
every single time okay so that's still
like the general happy path and the the
like the easy sad path but there are yet
more sad paths that I have to worry
about there's oh there's one less piece
so I just showed this dispatcher but I
didn't show the code that actually calls
it so something has to actually know
that these things are going on with
documents and actually know to say this
message that this document has things
that needs to communicate so go ahead
and communicate to the outside world so
if I have a single document that has to
coordinate by the way if your pictures
ever this complicated like revisit your
architecture it should not only like be
like maybe one or two things not like
ten that we see here anyway as a request
happens what I will do is register each
of the documents into a unit of work and
what that unit of work is just keeping
track of what things have gone on with
this request so then at the end of the
request I go it can go ahead and least
try to dispatch each of those i h of
those messages to their outbox so the
unit of work is the thing that's calling
the dispatcher that says okay i did the
first document that thing succeeded I
wrote appropriate okay now it needs to
go to the second documents to say let's
do those things
and finally keeps going and going
eventually something may fail and so
what we'll do is create a message
against you try to retry that individual
document so at least it partially
partially succeeded but maybe not
completely succeeded when it retries you
can go ahead and start from the top and
say it'll go and retry this overall
operation and because each of these
documents has kept track of what it's
done it in boxes then each operation
will just do it no op until it gets to
that final document that says okay now
something has actually gone wrong
we haven't actually processed this
message yet and so let's go ahead and do
whatever operation that it said it's
going to do okay
so I'll show this with our last piece
which is a unit of work in a repository
all right
still not duplicating here we go okay so
I said something was actually calling
dispatch to dispatch these messages and
that is going to be our unit of work our
unit of work is just an object that
keeps track of what things have been
happening during this request if you're
like in Happyland where you're just
using any framework you don't worry
about this pattern like it just keeps
track of stuff that has happened and
knows to go ahead and commit that
transaction at the end well we don't
live in happy land we live in sad cosmos
TV land
we don't have that our disposal so we
have to invent or not invent we have to
implement these patters ourselves so
we're going to implement the unit of
work pattern that has its own internal
identity map which just keeps track of
what documents have been worked with
during this request and then as things
happen inside my request they will get
registered with my identity map so I
could have one document that gets
registered or maybe multiple documents
are gonna get registered and then when I
complete the request for whatever that
means this is like the commit part of a
transaction then all this is doing is
looping through my set of documents I've
worked with find any messages with the
have any finding any documents with
messages in their outbox and then go
ahead and calling the dispatcher for
each and
document so this ensures that when I
click the button on the webpage at least
makes it a good attempt to try to
process every single message of the
outbox of any documents I've worked with
but if something goes wrong something
happens then it will go ahead and say go
ahead and dispatch that message that
individual document offline so this
could flag the record for reprocessing
it could drop a message in a queue this
is just like hey something went wrong
like go process this sometime later in
the future and so this gets called in
this case I think it's gets part of a a
filter that just says ok around each
request when I'm doing some operation go
ahead and do the thing ifs and then when
I'm done with the thing you're supposed
to do go ahead and complete the unit of
work and this will go ahead and try to
dispatch everything out into my
individual documents so they'd have like
at least when I click the button it will
try to go ahead and dispatch all those
messages to all the documents when I'm
loading things up that was part of this
register that I had over here if I want
to try to load a document from the
database then I actually do have a
repository pattern like one of the few
times that actually I'm okay with this
repository pattern because it will go
ahead and check my overall you need to
work to say do you already have this
thing and if you don't have this thing
then we'll go ahead and register the
thing after I load it out of Cosmos TV
and if you do have the thing then I will
just return that back out because you've
already asked for it this is the stuff
that again like entity framework and
other ORM just do for you you don't even
know that they do for you but if you
want to try to have a multi multi
resource operation these are the kind of
patterns you have to start implementing
yourself by the way there's like way
more things that can go wrong with this
so just don't just take this and run in
production there's a lot more things you
have to worry about in the gist
registering and finding here okay so
with that in place I've got a way to
take messages from one document process
them with another via the dispatcher if
I'm doing more than one thing as part of
a
then I have a unit of work that is
keeping track of everything that
everything that's happening to note a
disk to try to dispatch everything and
then finally if something goes wrong
then I have some way to say oops
something went wrong and go ahead and
just try to dispatch that message
offline okay so this last piece is the
one I want to show that it's like what
happens when things go really really
wrong with this picture all right so
what happens when something goes like
SuperDuper wrong that is I've got this
like multi document coordinated activity
that I'm trying to have as part of like
a lockstep I cated very much like a
canal lock sort of behavior where I have
one document of time cording with others
but then I have this this this poor
document at the end that fails and so we
had like we need a way to be able to get
notified that that thing failed and we
want to retry that one individual
document but what happens when like the
unit of work fails and then it had those
in-memory documents and it can't retry
it at that point then something has to
know to retry these documents in the
future now there's a number of ways you
can do this and really depends on what
tools are at your disposal for whatever
database you're working with but one way
we do with cosmos TV and MongoDB was via
a trigger they don't call them triggers
in cosmos TV because right nobody
actually wants to develop triggers on a
database it's like a bad thing to do so
they're called something else but that
general idea is that when something
updates a document you can have a piece
of code that executes based on whatever
actually happened with that original
document so what this trigger is
listening for are updates to documents
that have messages in their outbox so
what I can do is have something
listening for changes happening and as
changes are happening see if anything
needs processing and everything these
processing they go ahead and for that on
to the retry cue alright so let's look
at demo for that
okay so the piece we have there is what
happens when something fails between
here and here so this is a this is like
a proactive attempt to try to notify my
background processing like something
went wrong during this operation like
try to just process this via via offline
processing and this behind the scenes
will drop a message onto a broker or a
queue to say go ahead and process this
thing but if something fails like right
before there then how do we recover from
this failure so what we're going to be
using our triggers inside of Cosmos DB
to be able to be notified that something
went wrong so cosmos DB calls these
document feed observers and I could be
the implement this interface I change
feed observer and the general idea is
that for any an individual collection
you want to be notified for certain
things that have happened so like when
something changes for example like
something happens with it then you have
a set of code that gets called based on
that it passes you a list of documents
that have changed since the last time
it's checked and what we would do is
just basically loop through these
documents find anything that has items
to process in its outbox
and if it has things to process in its
outbox then I'm what I'm gonna do
instead of me trying to process
immediately I will immediately get into
some kind of durable format to say
process this document and so that's what
this last piece is it just says I'm
gonna create a durable message that goes
on to a real actual cue and go ahead and
process this meant this these documents
immediately behind the scenes what this
will do for us is really just call the
dispatcher for that individual document
and then eventually like with a bunch of
generic stuff it will do the same we'd
think we did before loop through the
outbox find the handler for each
individual document document message
call the handler process the document
message which means take it off of the
outbox and then finally save the
original document so it's the exact same
thing we were doing before except now
this is part of a back
processing trigger to be able to say
when things get updated to go ahead and
have something that can kind of catch up
if things go wrong now I have this
configured I think yeah this is a bunch
of crazy config code but eventually I
have different change feed processors
and what I'll do is I'll delay it by
some amount of time like 15 seconds so
cosmos DB normally it will just like
call your trigger immediately not really
well I don't want it to do that I only
want to do that if something went wrong
so I said well like if just wait a
little bit and then go ahead and check
just make sure everything went through
okay and then you can go ahead and try
to process everything so this works on a
15 second delay that after I've made any
change to a document check to see if it
has any messages in its outbox and if it
does then go ahead and fire message on
to as your service bus or RabbitMQ to
say like process this message and all of
its stuff inside of something that can
be more easily managed now there are
other ways I've done this like you could
have triggers on a database table you
can have just like a nightly batch
process once a night look for anything
that has messages in its outbox and go
ahead and process these things depending
on like how quickly you need to be able
to dispatch those messages between
documents that's basically what I try to
do based on this for this customer in
particular was a manufacturing company
and so we just like we calculated how
long it would take from one Operator to
walk from one station to the other and
get upset or pissed off at something
there's about 15 seconds from them to
walk from one station the other and they
say oh and I actually went through ok
they go ahead and walk back everything's
ok so that's how we figure it out that's
SLA is just measuring someone's speed of
walking and how know what they'd get ok
so with this background processing I've
got I've got my change feed going I've
got document messages going from one
place to the next let's actually run
this to make sure I am you've got
everything working ok so this example is
using Azure cosmos DB for my data
storage it's using RabbitMQ to shuttle
the messages between different
components
and then it's just a really ugly asp net
core front-end that i think i just took
from one of microsoft's examples because
that's the easiest thing to do animation
I made sure and restored all my new J
packages before I came here because the
the Wi-Fi here is not that great so it
should run okay here Oh bill failed what
did I do
it actually did fail restoring so what
I'll do is I'll so if we can just run it
without restoring packages
okay
I think what I did was I need to let's
try now
okay
so clearly I just need the Internet's to
make this work all right let's do this
I wish I could run the last running
instance do you know how to do that Seth
no okay hmm oh I'm on some other junk
wife I already know your password it's
fine okay well if this was working Wow
what we would see is a web UI in which I
start the start the interaction by
adding some items to my carts and when I
check out it will I'm gonna try to get
this Wi-Fi working that's annoying
now
well that's not a good sign endless
gifts okay that's fine
no no it's funny I like everything local
to make sure it works and of course this
happens so anyway with all this these
components in place that is a user
interface that only assumes that one
individual transaction succeeds or fails
with each individual documents and then
I have document messages to be able to
coronate between individual resources
that I can't put inside one single
transaction and then having a background
processor they can catch up when things
go wrong means that I can safely have
operations that can interact with
multiple transactional resources and
still have everything all kind of
succeed or kind of fail now in this case
because of using cosmos DB or MongoDB I
don't have the ability to have multi
document transactions but there are some
cases in which we do have the ability to
have like transactions just beyond just
that one single document so for the last
part I'm going to talk about some of the
like more I guess some more normal
scenarios that have run into on a daily
basis because most of my clients don't
actually use document databases you know
they're not that I don't know they're
not that brave to be able to run these
kinds of things in production almost the
time they've got like they just got
regular databases and regular
applications but they still can't do
these coordinated transactions so some
of the things I typically run into in a
production kind of scenario I'm not
using MongoDB I'm using sequel server
but I am using some kind of broker or
message queue that doesn't support
transactions between those two things so
how do I approach these scenarios when I
have these two things that I really like
they're normal things that everyone
works with but I can't put these two
things in a transaction so how do I
approach it using these patterns as we
saw earlier well the first thing I do is
I try to find what are my transactional
boundaries what are the things that I
can absolutely guarantee can either
succeed or fail for each of the
resources I'm dealing with so in MongoDB
the transactional boundaries
each individual documents but for sequel
server its it's the whole database right
want to make a connection open a
transaction I can write to multiple
tables multiple rows and see of a single
transaction and that can also cedar from
hit or fail but I can't coordinate that
sequel server with that RabbitMQ queue
so what I have to do is introduce that
outbox pattern to be able to coordinate
those activities between writing
something to the database and writing
something to a queue so what we'll do is
introduce an outbox table and instead of
having each document have its own inbox
and outbox I'll just create tables
inside a sequel server for those inboxes
and for those ad boxes so my train might
whatever my transactional boundary is is
the scope in which I put my inbox and my
outbox
what about micro-services right because
we're all doing that today right
everyone's doing micro-services in those
I have boundaries around each of my each
of my service boundaries and so each
service owns its own sequel or whatever
data store it has so for each of those
I'll have its own individual outbox then
a to dispatch messages to external
services so my dispatcher will read
messages out of that outbox of whatever
that outbox is and need to forward that
message on to some kind of broker but
what we don't want to do is just
directly expose those internal like see
Sharpie messages from my own internal
store to the outside world so we'll have
some kind of translator that translates
those internal messages into what I want
to actually expose to other services
other interested parties so those
messages will eventually be consumed by
my other service the other service will
receive those messages from the outside
world pass them on through a dispatcher
and then that own dispatcher will have
whatever it means to have its own inbox
whatever it's doing buying the scenes so
in this picture and maybe to sequel
server databases but it could be one
Kaiser cosmos TV database one sequel
database it could be neo4j n1n and I
don't know Cassandra on the other but
the general idea is that I will have to
have some way of keeping track of who
I've told what in order to make sure
that when I receive communication how I
I then done this operation before so our
overall lessons from here distributor
transactions are super easy when there
is no network like you can turn on all
the services on your box then
everything's gonna work great
but as soon as you go to production
that's when things get hard so when do
you when you start to actually
distribute resources distributed
transactions or hard or in a lot of
cases just plain impossible so in order
to work a way around this we have to
find what is the transactional boundary
but behind each of those resources and
introduce an out box in each of those
resources to be able to facilitate
communication between each of those
transactional boundaries so that was
finding life beyond distributed
transactions and apostates actual
implementation with real code that does
work if I'm not actually on the network
I guess so if you want more information
about this I've got a whole blog series
about each of these patterns one step at
a time on my blog otherwise you can find
the actual working example out of my
github.com /j bogart otherwise i hope
you enjoyed it I hope you have a great
rest of the conference thank you
[Applause]